he was a good president I think but
people will remember him for is what he
did after the presidency he didn't
capitalize on being president he got it
on boards he didn't make a whole lot of
money I think he still lives today in
the home that he grew up in Plains
Georgia I had the opportunity to meet
him several times he has a decency is
the word he is a very his family is very
decent down to earth ordinary uh people
uh I was with him a number of years ago
at the Carter Center which was really
really good work among other things
making sure that elections held around
the world are done democratically and
fairly so he has lived out his
post-presidential years with a lot of
dignity we should all be proud of what
he is accomplishing